it is my pleasure to introduce Martha
Pollack dr. Pollack is the 14th
president of Cornell University as
faculty at the University of Michigan
dr. Pollock and dr. J hey nian forged a
strong friendship I'm pretty sure that
neither of them imagined that they'd be
here today as president of two of the
best universities in the United States
their presidencies came come in at
important time in history when were
presented with new opportunities and
challenges on a daily basis technology
is moving forward at an amazing pace
it's impacting all areas of research
transforming how we teach and blending
the lines between disciplines dr.
Shahani and Pollock are the right time
of leader at the right time
bold innovative forward-thinking we need
to make our institutions a transport
transformational part of this time since
becoming the president of corn even
Cornell University about a year and a
half ago dr. Pollock has demonstrated a
strong commitment to sustaining and
enhancing Cornell's academic distinction
while enhancing equality diversity and
inclusivity she is supporting the
university's expansion into New York
City where it has programs that range
from architecture to technology to
medicine dr. Pollack came to Cornell
University from the University of
Michigan where she was provost and
executive vice president for academic
affairs before her tenure at Michigan
she actually served she served on the
University of Pittsburgh's faculty so
welcome back to Pittsburgh
dr. Pollock is renowned for her
contributions in computer science and
artificial intelligence her research
focuses on automated automated planning
temporal reasoning and constraint
satisfaction she has designed
intelligent technology to assist people
with cognitive impairments and their
caregivers dr. Pollock has also served
as president of the Association for the
Advancement of artificial intelligence
and was a member of the Advisory
Committee for the National Science
Foundation's computers and information
science engineering division and a
member of the board of directors of the
computing Research Association please
join me in welcoming dr. Martha Pollack
Thank You Rebecca good morning to all of
you I am truly honored to be here today
for the inauguration of my colleague and
friend Farnum Jahan e'en as the tenth
president of Carnegie Mellon University
most of you probably don't know this but
there's an historical connection between
Carnegie Mellon and my own University
Cornell Andrew Carnegie was one of
Cornell's first trustees elected to that
role in 1890 later honoring his passion
for music Carnegie donated to Cornell a
magnificent organ to celebrate the 80th
birthday of our first president Andrew
Dickson white alas the organ suffered an
ignoble fate its air intake for some
inexplicable reason was located in the
men's bathroom and in 1935 there was a
plumbing failure that filled that room
with water unaware of this the
university organist sat down at the
instrument and according to the
historical account blew a mighty
crescendo which filled the leather organ
pouches with water ruining them perhaps
we didn't better off with a gift of
bagpipes now there is also a longtime
connection between Farnham amel though
of course not as long as between our
universities as Rebecca said Farnham and
I met about 20 years ago when we were
both faculty members in computer science
and engineering at the University of
Michigan I later became chair of CSC and
Farnham succeeded me in that role later
he became Provost here at Carnegie
Mellon a few years after I had become
Provost at Michigan and he started as
interim president here just a couple of
months after I became Cornell's
president
[Applause]
but I'm gonna take that couple of months
headstart seriously and imagine that it
gives me the right to offer him some
advice on leadership specifically I'd
like to quote hopper the grasshopper in
the animated movie a bug's life
who said this quote first rule of
leadership everything is your fault I
need to tell you this Farnum butt
hoppers right especially when you're the
president of a university but really
having everything be your fault is a
fair trade-off for all that is wonderful
about being a university president it is
as I know Farnum appreciates a huge
privilege to lead a university
especially a great one like Carnegie
Mellon universities are institutions
that are second to none in changing
lives we change the lives of our
students we change the lives of the
communities into which our students
graduate and we change the lives of all
those who are touched by the research
and the scholarship of our faculty
Farnum I can assure you is the perfect
choice to lead Carnegie Mellon and to
ensure that it continues its proud
tradition of changing lives for the
better he has a range of experience
that's an extraordinary fit for this
university experience in academia where
he's been a talented and dedicated
teacher as well as a renowned researcher
whose discoveries have had broad impact
experience in industry where he founded
a very successful network security
startup company and experience in
government where he served in major
roles at the National Science Foundation
the National Research Council's computer
science and telecommunications board and
more but beyond all that what I want you
to know is that Farnum also has a set of
personal characteristics that are from
incomplete alignment with Carnegie
Mellon's culture he is a person of high
integrity who values and exhibits
creativity innovation and
entrepreneurship he values and promotes
mentorship and the development of
leadership skills as essential to
pairing students for today's world he
appreciates the importance of a
university supporting a breadth of
intellectual inquiry but he also has a
particular passion for translational
research that produces results that
directly benefit society he's focused on
the ways in which technology can enhance
all aspects of the university from
teaching to research to operations a few
years ago when Alan G Merton retired
from the presidency of George Mason
University he said this quote do I like
being a university president I don't
know but I do know that I have loved
being George Mason University's
president some of my friends are
university presidents I wouldn't want to
be where they are and they probably
wouldn't want to be here these jobs can
look a lot alike but they are not end
quote search committees look for
university presidents who fit their
University and I can't imagine Carnegie
Mellon finding someone who fits better
than Farnham he will be a brilliant and
inspired leader for this wonderful
University and who knows he may even
learn to play the bagpipes
[Applause]